all right first classic interview of the
new year we're gonna go back to my
interview with James Kilgore a former
inmate who actually understands the
prison system spoke to us about the
prison system this is from September of
2015 and as I reviewed this interview to
run it for you this week especially for
people who never saw it when it
originally aired I was thinking of
rather than how far we've come with
regard to reforming our prison system
since I did this interview back in 2015
I was thinking of the opposite how we
haven't really advanced much in terms of
our thinking and our sophistication and
our understanding about the problems
with America's prison system so that's
how I was thinking of the interview
maybe you'll think about it the same way
maybe not my interview with James
Kilgore from September of 2015 is this
week's classic interview James Kilgore
was the last fugitive member of the
Symbionese Liberation Army and he spent
six years in prison for the murder of a
Sacramento housewife during an April
1975 bank robbery the Symbionese
Liberation Army is the 1970s era group
notorious for bank robberies and
killings and the kidnapping of Patricia
Hearst and during his time in prison
James drafted his three published novels
he teaches at the University of Illinois
at urbana-champaign and his new book is
called understanding mass incarceration
a people's guide to the key civil rights
struggle of our time James joins me now
James sometimes mass incarceration and
the sort of mass incarceration status
quo in the United States is described as
a sort of experiment can you talk about
that a little bit in what ways is our
status quo with incarceration a sort of
experiment well I think it's beyond the
experimental stage it's been going on
for over 30 years
and it's a qualitative change in the way
in which the u.s. government deals with
not only criminal justice but poverty
more broadly so we've seen that prison
and jail population expand from less
than half a million in 1980 to over 2.2
million today we've seen the budgets
that amount of money that's spent on
incarceration from grow from about six
billion to over eighty billion today so
I think we're beyond the experimental
stage I think it's become really part of
the lay of the land I think Brian
Stevenson the the author of just mercy
and excellent book on this topic has
said that mass incarceration now defines
us as a society I don't think it's an
experiment unfortunately and it's going
to take a very powerful social movement
and a very powerful set of policy
changes in order to end this established
practice no I certainly agree with that
I guess the the I used the term
experiment more in the sense that we we
didn't really have any data telling us
that some of the sort of stated
objectives of the incarceration status
quo would actually reduce crime and we
were sort of being told source old this
bill of goods that hey listen we get we
get criminals off of the street you
prevent them from committing crimes in
the future the war on drugs which was
incredibly racially tinged was presented
as a way to sort of prevent nonviolent
drug offenders and low-level drug
dealers from sort of graduating to more
serious crime and didn't it fail in the
sense that in many ways the
incarceration status quo may be creating
more crime than it prevents absolutely
the the expansion of prisons and jails
has created havoc in many communities in
the country
Eric Ghidorah has come up with the idea
of million dollar blocks where the state
is spending more than a million dollars
on locking up people from blocks and
specific in specific neighborhoods these
are neighborhoods made up largely of
poor people of color not only have
thousands of people been taken from
these communities to prisons and jails
but also the social welfare provision in
those communities has been has been cut
back so the means of economic and social
survival in those communities has been
made more difficult and to top that off
we've seen an acceleration of police
these communities and the pouring of
dollars into resources to develop SWAT
squads to arm police with m16s and
armored personnel carriers and so forth
all of this has created an environment
where we're much more likely to have
crime or much more likely to be
provoking arrests and we're much more
likely to have policing that looks to
arrest and punish people rather than to
solve community problems so I want to
talk a little bit about some of the
changes we've seen over the last 10 to
15 years and I've talked many times on
my program about how 9/11 and the sort
of desire for security that it caused
was successfully used to pass everything
from the Patriot Act to scale up NSA
surveillance etc you write in your book
about how 9/11 was also used to
intensify the war on drugs and I think
maybe people are less familiar with how
that works so tell us a little bit about
that well I think 9/11 contributed to
the kind of internationalization of the
war on drugs and blaming some of the
elements of excessive drug use in the
communities on what was happening in
Mexico and South America so that then
also connected to an anti-immigrant
policy which we see today and that is in
in since the the year 2000 we've seen in
a tremendous increase in deportations
we've also seen criminalization of
immigrants on the guys that they are
likely to be bringing in drugs but the
the population for example of Latinos in
the prison system has increased by 50
percent since the year 2000 a much
faster growth rate than any other
population group we've also set up
special prison prisons criminal alien
prisons which are set up specifically
for people who have immigration offenses
and are labeled criminals and made to do
time in many cases even for simply
crossing the border people can do up to
ten years even up to 20 years if they
prior arrests previously when people
were convicted of illegal entry they
were simply taken to the border and sent
back across now people can do years in
prison for offenses like that and even
though private prisons make up a
relatively small portion of the total
number of prisons in the United States
the private prisons are
disproportionately capitalizing on the
detention of undocumented immigrants and
this has become a huge moneymaker has it
not absolutely the private prisons david
have found immigration to be their
market niche so they hold only about 9%
of prison beds across the country but
about 40% of the immigration detention
beds and this has become their this is
really Salvage them at the turn of the
century private prisons were in very
difficult financial straits there were a
number of scandals going on
but Steve Cornell who was the head of
one of the private prison companies at
the time said that after 9/11 that
immigration was going to be the future
of private prisons and he's been proven
correct not only are they building
detention facilities but they also spend
a lot of time lobbying federal and state
governments for harsher immigration laws
in order to increase the numbers of
people that are held in detention
they are also contracting for
supervision of people who are awaiting
immigration judicial procedures so for
example the the bi incorporated which is
a subset of the geo group the second
biggest private prison provider they
have a contract to keep 7,000 people on
electronic monitors who are awaiting
decisions about asylum or deportation
applications so really immigration is
that is their baby and they're trying to
promote harsher laws and they also
participated in in the in advocating for
the laws in Arizona Alabama Mississippi
and so forth that have tightened up
immigration policy is there an
opportunity today where we find
ourselves today with regard to
incarceration to start undo
some of the elements that have
contributed to what we now see is there
anything in particular going on right
now that might serve as a sort of
entryway to starting to shake up what
has clearly been a failed system I think
there's a lot going on things that we
haven't seen previously and I'd just
like to mention two the first is at the
top we've begun to see some bipartisan
discourse against mass incarceration
mass incarceration has become a
political issue Hillary Clinton's
talking about it
Newt Gingrich's talking about it the
president has talked about it
it wasn't even mentioned in the 2012
political campaign and now across the
board you're seeing partnerships Rand
Paul joining hands with Cory Booker and
so forth to try to find ways to reduce
the jail and prison population in many
instances simply because too much money
was being spent on Corrections to the
detriment of state and local governments
but secondly and I think more
importantly we've seen huge amounts of
mass action across the country at the
community level and at the national
level and and I don't think we can
divorce all of the activities that have
taken place in response to the killings
of Michael Brown and Eric garner Tamir
rice and so forth from the whole system
of mass incarceration and a racialized
criminal justice system and connected to
that has been the resurgence of
immigrant rights activities forcing the
president to modify his stance on
deportation and to relieve five million
people from immediate threat of
deportation
the government's reactions to these
phenomenon are largely because there's a
fear that if they don't take some kind
of ameliorative action we'll end up with
uprisings across the across the country
so I think apart from those uprisings
there's hundreds of projects and
campaigns across the country against
private prisons against cash bail
against prison building against jail
building and programs for people
returning from prison a whole host of
things that are being addressed by
people who are on the move in a way
we've never
seen before in the last two decades I'll
remind you that the book is
understanding mass incarceration of
people's guide to the key civil rights
struggle of our time we've been speaking
with the book's author James Kilgore
James really a pleasure to have you on
thanks very much David